[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLIOTT HUGHES: So today, we
do not want to get any new C++
users.
We hope that you will use
Java or Kotlin if you can.
But obviously there are people
who can't, and we're here
for you.
And so I think what we
really want to say is just,
we are working on C and C++.
We do care.
We're trying to
make things better,
and we want to talk
about some of the things
that we've been doing
over the past few years.
So specifically, we are the
platform, the OS, C++ team.
And we took over the
NDK around 2015 for r10.
The parts that we
consider the NDK
are basically the compiler,
the headers, and the libraries.
So we're not talking about
things like the Studio
integration, the Gradle stuff.
The Studio folks are around,
they've got numerous talks
and you can talk to
them other times.
So Dan's going to start with a
introduction to what we've done
since we took over the NDK.
DAN ALBERT: Yes.
So like Elliott said, we
took over in about May 2015.
That was NDK r10e at the time.
So I'm going to be
covering from then on.
To give some perspective what
the OS C++ experience looked
like back then, this
was Marshmallow.
We were most of the
way done with that.
We had the transition to Clang
well underway at that point.
We'd moved a device
in its entirety.
We were working on others.
We had complete C++14 support
from libc++ at that point.
Google is big on dogfooding,
so the idea being we
should be using
what you're using
so that we find the bugs
before we ship them to you.
Unfortunately for
the NDK at the time,
this is what things looked like.
We had four different compilers.
So that was two versions of
GCC, two versions of Clang.
Clang was heavily forked.
Three different C++ libraries.
We had stlport, hadn't received
updates upstream in years so it
was still in C++03.
We had the gnustl, more commonly
known as GNUs libstdc++.
That's what you have in
your normal Linux system.
And libc++, which is LLVMs
C++ standard library which
we're using in the platform.
This was also quite
heavily forked in the NDK,
and it had a
compatibility library
that let it run going
back to Gingerbread.
And that library had quite
a few bugs, unfortunately.
So that was a major
source of issues.
We also had a copy
of the OS headers
for every single API
level and architecture.
And typically that meant that if
we fixed a bug in the headers,
we only fixed it in
the most recent version
and it didn't get backported.
Which was a big
problem because you
were using whichever
version of the headers
matched your min SDK version.
So if we only fixed
the latest version,
you wouldn't actually see
the fix for about five years,
maybe more.
So the question is how do we
get to this dogfooding world.
And we could
essentially either just
stop shipping NDKs
for a couple of years
while we dealt with
all of the issues that
had to get us there.
That didn't sound
particularly appealing,
so instead we tried
to do this in smaller,
less disruptive steps.
Each step still had
some disruption,
but it was a much easier
hurdle to get over.
We did this in a predictable
opt in, opt out, and then remove
cycle.
If I use the unified
headers as an example, r14
we added a flag
to turn those on.
r15, if your app wasn't
ready to switch yet,
you could still opt out
with a different flag.
And then by r16 we had
worked out all the kinks
and we were ready to move on, so
we removed the previous option.
The compilers, we started
with this really with r11.
That was when we
unforked the NDKs Clang,
and that alone let us
close just a ton of bugs.
It was then the same compiler
that we used to build the OS.
r13 couple releases
later we switched
that to be the default.
And then by r18 it was--
we were to the point that
we could actually rely fully
on Clang and libc++,
so we removed GCC.
At this point, all of
Android, all of ChromeOS, iOS,
all of these are using Clang.
So if you are targeting a subset
of these operating systems,
your code is much more likely
to be portable between them.
The unified headers I
had mentioned earlier,
this is the gist of
what those look like.
Instead of having a different
copy of this header for every
single API level, we have
this annotation here,
__INTRODUCED_IN, that says that
dlvsym was not available until
Android 24.
The compiler will make sure
that you can't actually
build against that if your min
SDK version is not at least 24.
We still have all of the types,
the macros, the constants,
all the things that you need
to use these APIs visible.
So if you are running--
if your min SDK version
is lower than the device
you're actually running
on, you can still
access the new API with dlsym
and use all the correct types
rather than copy pasting
all the types and constants
into your project,
like you would have to
with the previous solution.
This did unearth
a handful of bugs.
It was mostly actually
old Android workarounds
that had been checked in,
had to be deleted in order
to work with the new option.
But deleting code's
pretty straightforward,
so that's not too bad.
libc++.
Like I said, this
was one of the more--
this was really our main goal,
was to give you a up to date
C++ standard library.
Something that actually could
support C++11 at the time
and then 14 and now even 17.
It was a fairly long
road to get there.
It required those
previous fixes first.
In r16 was when we really
started doing this in earnest.
We rewrote that compatibility
library with all the bugs,
added a whole bunch
of tests, made sure
that that was nice and solid.
And we shipped that in r16, took
the beta sticker off and said,
yes, please start using this.
It wasn't the default yet.
We waited for r17 for that.
So r17 it became the default.
And then r18 everything
was looking good and we
removed the other options.
So as of r18 the NDK had a
single compiler, the same one
we used to build the OS.
A single set of headers, same
ones we used to build the OS.
And a single C++ library,
the same one we used to build
the operating system.
So it was dogfooding
mission accomplished.
[APPLAUSE]
Does this mean that there's
no more disruption when
you update your NDK?
Unfortunately, not quite.
There are still a few changes we
are going to need to be making.
This is particularly to
reduce the size of the NDK.
There's a whole bunch of
redundant copies of things
right now.
And if you're build
system is currently
relying on those
redundant copies, when
I go to delete them your
build system's going to break.
Fortunately as long as
you're on NDK r19 or newer,
ndk-build and CMake, our two
officially supported options,
are already onto this.
So as long as you're using
those, you're already covered.
If you do have your
own build system,
there is fortunately a
doc linked down there
at the bottom that
will tell you all
that you need to know to
actually integrate this
into your own build system.
Aside from that, we do have
the two build systems still.
ndk-build is alive and well.
It is purpose built for Android.
So often, if you are
targeting only Android,
that is actually going to
be your easiest option.
That is not the normal case.
You are probably also
targeting iOS, Windows, handful
of other platforms.
In that case, CMake
is your best bet.
It is going to be the easiest
option for cross platform work.
And with that, I'm handing
off to Elliott for debugging.
ELLIOTT HUGHES: Hi.
So I think it's not really going
to be much of a surprise that
the first thing to
talk about with C, C++,
debugging is memory issues.
So like I said at the start,
we are the OS C++ team.
So any kind of
problem that you guys
are having in apps, we've
been having in the OS
itself for a long time.
Typically we've
used ASan for this.
This is a new hardware
accelerated ASan,
and hopefully we'll talk
about that some other time.
But right now ASan is kind of
the state of the art for this.
That's what we're
using for platform.
And what we're going
to talk about today
is how you can use
this in the NDK.
It is supported in the NDK, it's
just perhaps less well known.
So these are the kind of
issues that ASan can find.
It's basically everything
except for leaks.
For leaks we use malloc debug.
You can find documentation for
that on developer.android.com
as well, in the same place
as the ASan documentations.
But the key thing I want to
talk about is this wrap.sh.
So ASan on Android is
interesting in that the way it
works is that you have this
LD_PRELOAD, this shared
library that has to get loaded
before your code starts.
Basically, it intercepts
all of the memory allocation
and freeing operations.
And to do that,
it obviously needs
to be running before any
allocations are actually made.
Normally this
wouldn't be a problem,
but on Android when
your app starts,
you're not actually
starting from scratch.
You're starting from
a clone of the zygote.
Which, you know, it's
generally helpful.
It reduces your app
startup time greatly
because the common startup
that every app would
have to do have all
the framework stuff
has already happened.
If you want more details
about the zygote,
the art folks are going to be
giving a talk tomorrow morning
where they'll be talking about
some of the new optimizations
they've done to that in Q.
But for our purposes,
all you need to know
is this kind of gets
and your way for ASan.
So what we added
was a thing where
if you have a shell script
in your APK called wrap.sh
and in the correct directory,
when the zygote comes
to launch your app, instead of
cloning what's already there
it actually starts
completely from scratch.
So here's an example of what
such a shell script could
look like.
So $@ is basically shell
for all the arguments.
So what's happening here is
when Android calls your wrap.sh,
it gives you the
exact command line
that it would
otherwise have run.
So here we're just
saying, do what
you would have done anyway.
So the only difference is you're
in a completely fresh process.
You're not cloned
from the zygote.
And anything that you
output to stdout or stderr
will go to the log.
It will go to logcat
rather than just being
lost like it normally would.
Again because the assumption
is you're debugging here,
you want to see anything.
So here's a slightly more
interesting version, then.
This is saying-- so
the ASan options,
there's a link a
couple of slides
ago for all the details about
the different ASan options.
This is just an example of
like, here are common options
that you will want if you're
using ASan on Android.
So that puts that
into the environment
for when you're app starts.
LD_PRELOAD, like I
said, that's a clue
to the dynamic linker when
you start with this app,
load this library first.
And this is, kind of,
the runtime for ASan.
ndk-build knows about this.
It will do this magic for you.
There's a little wrinkle
with Studio at the moment,
that we need to teach Studio
to actually package this.
If you're not using
Studio, you don't really
need to do anything.
If you are, definitely go
to developer.android.com.
You can see the
docs about wrap.sh,
and we've got an example of
that that has screenshots
of what you need to do.
If you're using ndk-build, this
is more what it looks like.
In your Android.mk
file, you literally just
tell a compiler please turn
on address sanitization.
The -fno-omit-frame-pointer
thing is so that we can give
you good quick unwinds.
Like I say, if you do this,
ndk-build picks up on that.
It spots that you've
said sanitize address,
and it'll actually set
up the wrap.sh for you.
So like I say, lots more
documentation on that.
It is kind of complicated, but
once you get the hang of it
it's not too bad.
There's documentation about
that on developer.android.com
that includes a few examples.
File bugs if you have
trouble with any of that.
So another thing we have that--
we've been using this,
again, the platform
has used this since 2012.
We've used this for
a long time now.
But by default, NDK users
aren't getting this.
If you want us to catch easy,
sort of, buffer overrun bugs
if you define
_FORTIFY_SOURCE to 2--
again, you can look this
up on the web for details.
You define _FORTIFY_SOURCE,
you can actually have us behind
the scenes.
The compiler, if it can do
so, will prove at compile time
that your code is either
correct or incorrect.
It is incorrect, it will
just spew out an error
and you can fix
it there and then.
If it can't prove it, it'll
actually insert a call
to a slightly
different routine that
will do some runtime checking.
So in this example, this
is something obviously
very contrived, but
this is something
that this static analysis
built into the compiler
doesn't actually spot.
It doesn't realize
that that 32 is
going to be used as
that parameter to read.
So it turns this
into a runtime check.
And if that fails, you then
get a nice, clear abort.
And the abort message will be
along the lines of, you know,
fortify the specific
function you called and then
what you asked it
to do and what it
thinks the current
state of the world is.
Similar to that, an
even easier case.
We have a lot of app compat
use where SELinux policies have
changed or permissions
on some file have changed
or even the existence
of a file has changed.
But apps are assuming,
oh, I just open this file
and then I read from it.
And they kind of plow on without
actually checking for errors.
So it's simple cases
like that where
it's never valid to give a
null file pointer to any stdio
function.
So we will actually,
just on recent builds,
we'll just blow you
out of the water.
Nice clean abort.
Nice clean error message.
Another similar thing
on more recent builds
is that there's been a lot
of confusion about pthread_t,
which is what you get
from pthread_create
and you use with all the
other pthread functions,
and pid_t, which
is basically just
the integer that the kernel
uses for its raw thread.
And you do sometimes need
to deal with both of these
depending on what
your app is doing.
You can get a pid_t
from a pthread_t.
There's a p_thread gettid NP
function that you can call.
So if you're using some
kind of low level Linux API
that requires a tid,
you can do that.
What you can't do is
you can't give a tid,
you know, a pid, to one
of the pthread functions.
Historically, it would
just silently do nothing.
Because it would look on
its list of current threads,
say I've not heard of
that, that's not a thread,
and do nothing.
Nowadays, it actually
catches this-- again,
nice clear abort--
and tells you what you've done.
Usually this means-- if
it's a low number like this,
it means that you made this
pthread and tid confusion.
If it's a high
number, that means
you've lost track of
one of your threads.
It's basically the
thread equivalent
of, like, a double close
or an invalid free.
Those are often a
bit harder to debug.
Something brand new in Q
that's new to Android is fdsan.
So file descriptors, it's
what's behind the scenes of like
the stdio file or
the C++ file APIs.
It's an integer.
It's what the Linux kernel
uses to represent an open file.
And it's quite easy to mess
up the ownership of these.
And what's really unfortunate
is that the kernel
does a, kind of,
first fit allocation.
So if you allocate
five files and then
you close one and
open another, you'll
get that same number reused.
So it's really hard
to debug these.
So what we've done.
We've actually added tracking
for this to the C library.
The link at the
bottom explains how
if you've got higher
level classes that
control some resources
that have file descriptors,
you can actually
take part in this.
But we've wired up the basic
classes, the basic structs,
things like file and
stdio so that you--
this example on the
slide, for example.
This is a real bug that
we actually had in Android
that was found by this.
Obviously, the real one was
spread over multiple files
and hundreds of lines.
But it boils down to this.
That now is a nice clear abort.
Well there's actually two modes.
Again, see the documentation.
You can either-- by
default at the moment,
it just logs if
it finds an issue
and then lets you carry on.
So it preserves that, kind
of, backward buggy behavior.
Hopefully in future
we'll actually
make that fully
enforcing, but you can do
that yourself in the meantime.
So unwinding.
Whenever you have a crash,
you've seen the sort of stacks
that you get from that.
Behind the scenes,
there's piece of code
called the unwinder which is
basically just crawling up
your stack working
out what called what.
In the past, that really--
it worked fine for C and C++,
but it kind of fell apart when
it hit Java.
So one thing we've
done more recently.
We've written a
completely new unwinder.
And the major feature of that
is that it actually understands
Java and Kotlin frames.
It doesn't matter whether
they're ahead of time,
compiled, jitted,
or interpreted.
It will do the right thing.
In Q, we've added a few
extra little tricks.
ELF build IDs are useful.
Every object file,
every executable
you have has a
hash encoded in it.
We'll actually show those
hashes in Q so that you can--
sometimes you're not sure.
Like, is this is
this really the,
were they running the
right version of the code I
think they were running?
Am I debugging against
the wrong thing?
You can check it out.
So here's an example of what
the stacks used to look like.
The blue parts, the C++,
that used to work fine.
But as soon as we'd hit
Java, we'd basically stop.
Because the way Java--
the way they are at
runtime maintains
its stack is very different.
In P and Q, we've actually
taught it about that.
So this is the kind of
stack you'll get these days.
It doesn't even matter whether
it's interpreted or jitted.
We'll just do the right thing.
We even have if you
have your own JIT,
we actually use the same
kind of API behind the scenes
that things like
GDB use for this.
So you can actually tell us
about your own JITs as well.
What can you do when you
have a good unwinder?
Profiling is an obvious
thing that comes to mind.
In NDK r13, we shipped a
thing called simpleperf.
This is basically like
the Linux perf tool.
It's a command line
tool you can use.
It's useful, and
it was certainly
useful for the OS people.
Not so useful for
app developers,
because you can't generally
run your app whenever you want.
So one thing that we did
as a sort of stopgap was we
added a tool to give you
HTML flame graphs that you
could then see in the browser.
But obviously, the real
aim was the GUI profiler.
Hopefully you saw that.
This was released in Studio 3.1.
It was mentioned in
the Studio blog post.
And hopefully you've tried that.
If you haven't,
that might actually
be worth switching to
Studio so you can try that.
So this is what the
command line looks like.
Basically the same-- if anyone's
familiar with the Linux perf
tool, it's basically the same.
This is the separate
record and report steps.
We also support
annotation if you actually
want to see right down
to the assembler level
where was my code.
You can connect to
existing processes.
But again, the easiest way to
do that is just to use Studios.
The Studio UI is the
picture in the foreground.
Picture in the background is
the sort of HTML thing we have.
So now we'll talk about some
of the things that people hit
either when switching from
GCC to Clang or from gnustl
to libc++, or just, in fact,
in terms of upgrading between
different versions of the NDK.
DAN ALBERT: So this
was a very common issue
we saw when people were
updating to the unified headers.
You would update, and
suddenly your code
would no longer compile because
some function that really
ought to be there was missing.
Really common case for this
was mmap just disappeared.
The reason for this was that
Bionic supports this feature
called _FILE_OFFSET_BITS.
It allows you to
specify that you
want a 64-bit off_t so you
can deal with files larger
than two gigabytes.
This was a feature that
wasn't in older NDKs.
So if you set _FILE_OFFSET_BITS
when you were using an older
NDK, nothing happened.
It failed silently.
You got no indication
that nothing happened,
and it moved on.
When you then upgraded, you
were getting this feature.
And if you asked for it before
it was actually available,
your build would fail.
Fortunately, the fix for
this is extremely easy.
If all you want is
the old behavior back,
grep through your project,
find the line that says
_FILE_OFFSET_BITS.
It'll be in either one
of your build scripts
or possibly in one
of your source files.
Just delete that line and
everything will be back
to the way it was.
If you do need a
large file support,
the answer is a bit
more complicated.
Essentially you
need to figure out
what your min SDK
version is, what you're
OK with your min
SDK version being,
which subsets of
the APIs you need.
Fortunately, this is
really well documented.
The doc link there.
You can search in
our bug tracker.
If you have more
questions just file a bug.
We're happy to help.
ELLIOTT HUGHES: So
I think probably
everyone who has native
code has seen this.
You know, you run your
new version of your APK,
you get an unsatisfied
link error.
We had this ourselves
in the platform.
So we have debugging
information in there-- click.
If you set this property--
you don't need a rooted device
for this, debug
properties you can
set regardless--
you can actually
turn on the full logging from
the dynamic linker itself.
It'll tell you everything,
every file it considers,
and it'll tell you
why it didn't open it.
So rather than just this
short dlerror message
that you get in the
unsatisfied link error,
if you really want to see the
full information you can here.
No example of this because
it is just far too verbose.
DAN ALBERT: Another common
issue you'll run into,
particularly while
updating to a new compiler
or switching between different
types of compilers or even just
to a new version
of the compiler,
is undefined behavior.
C++ is full of
undefined behavior.
It's very exciting.
This can just lead to all
sorts of surprising behaviors
in your application.
So fortunately, Clang gives
you a really good tool
to try to sort out these issues.
It's undefined
behavior sanitizer.
Like with ASan, you can
enable this quite simply
in your Android.mk.
If you add these flags, instead
of just unpredictable behavior
at runtime, you will get a
nice stack trace and a crash
in logcat that explains
what went wrong
and where it went wrong.
This is also extremely useful
for a security conscious code.
It is much better to just
stop and restart rather than
continue into unpredictable
behavior for security reasons.
We actually ship with this on in
the platform for some modules.
Things like Stagefright, for
example, back in [INAUDIBLE] M,
whenever that was.
Undefined behavior
sanitizer was the only tool
we had that could
actually catch that bug.
And so we now keep
that on as a mitigation
ELLIOTT HUGHES:
Right so one thing
that also caused
trouble for people
who were switching
from GCC to Clang
is that Clang is a lot
fussier about assembler.
This example, there are
four different instructions
that that might be.
It's probably obvious to a
human which one that they meant,
but Clang refuses to guess.
GCC would just guess.
The workaround, if you don't
have time to work on this right
now and you just want to
get on with your life.
-fno-integrated-as.
That lets you use the binutils
assembler behind the scenes
so you'll get the
existing behavior.
We actually moved forward and
fixed all of the ambiguities
in our code.
The easy trick for doing
that is just use [INAUDIBLE]..
DAN ALBERT: Another
common problem.
You will go and update your SDK.
It will update the NDK with it.
And now your build is
broken because you're
Gradle plugin didn't upgrade.
There are a handful
of assumptions
that the Gradle plugin
will make about how
the NDK is structured.
We are doing everything we can
to remove those where possible.
But fortunately, there's
another really easy fix
for this problem.
Out in beta earlier
today with Studio 3.5,
you can actually
specify your NDK version
in your build.gradle right
alongside your Gradle plugin
version.
That way these two things
remain in lockstep.
You upgrade them
at the same time.
Everything will be fine.
Again, that is
Gradle 3.5 plugin.
So you will need that first,
but from then on you're covered.
This also lets you install
multiple versions of the NDK
easily.
So if you are working
on multiple projects
and you need different versions
of the NDK for each one
because the project
started at different times,
that's now nice and easy to do.
ELLIOTT HUGHES: So hopefully
you already read the blog posts
that we've had over the
past couple of years
about the move to 64-bit and
the requirement that everybody
supports it.
The main thing we
want to talk to you
about today is just some tips.
So we had this problem
back in Lollipop.
Like my team, we basically
spent the entire year
fixing all the code, all
the 32-bit assumptions.
For those of you who are already
running the same code on iOS,
you shouldn't have a problem.
You've already been
through this transition.
For those of you
aren't, the main thing
that caused trouble
for us was JNI code.
So places where you
have a Java class that
has some kind of native peer.
That was all using
jint for us, so we
had to go through and
catch all of those.
These warnings-- and this
actually turns these warnings
on and then make them errors.
This was completely necessary
for us to fix the platform.
These catch places where
you're converting a 32-bit int
to and from a pointer.
A trickier one, a
less obvious one,
is implicit function
declarations will hurt you
as well.
Because the old
K&R assumption is
that if you don't
tell the compiler what
the type of a function
is, the assumption
is that it returns int, which
means 32 bits, which means
it'll truncate your pointer.
So in this example, foo()
actually returns a char*.
We didn't tell a compiler that.
We ignored it's warning
about the implicit function
declaration, and
it said, fine, I'll
just drop those top 32 bits.
And obviously, that
doesn't go well at runtime.
So that's the thing to add
to your build if you actually
want it, the compiler, to
just say, no, this is wrong,
I'm not going to do that.
So Dan's now going to talk
about some of the things
that we're working on
for the near future.
DAN ALBERT: So somewhat
short term on the roadmap,
we are looking
into a new linker.
Right now we have
bfd and we have gold.
We are looking to
lld for the NDK.
We are already using
lld for the platform.
It, for one, is a lot faster.
For something like
linking the Linux kernel,
it is actually twice as fast.
So instead of a three
minute link step,
it is only a minute and a half.
It is also a lot better at
detecting ODR violations
and reporting them
in useful ways.
If you've ever tried to
debug one of those with one
of the other linkers,
it can be quite a pain.
It's also got better support
for the newer Clang features.
LTO will work better with lld.
This is already in the NDK
as an experimental feature.
It has been for a
release or two now.
It's still got some
rough edges in the NDK,
particularly on Windows.
It doesn't always work.
We are always working on this.
I believe r21 will have
most of those issues fixed.
However, other
cases it does work.
Like I said, we are
using this for the OS
so it does work in a
good number of cases.
If you are not impacted by
any of the existing bugs
and you do want your builds to
be faster, it is worth a shot.
If you do encounter
bugs, please file them.
This is still
quite early for us,
which is why there is
no solid roadmap here.
Normally we would
say, you know, we're
going to make this the
default in this release
and then remove it
and this release.
We haven't made it
to that point yet.
But please do try it
out if you get a chance.
A larger task here
is making it easier
to access third party libraries
in your NDK applications.
We want something as simple as
just apt install openssl-dev.
If you've ever tried
building that for Android,
it is quite a hassle.
It does not use any of our
supported build systems,
so you have to make their
build system work with the NDK.
It can be a hassle.
So we are investigating
a number of options
to make this easier for
you so you can just specify
this in your build.gradle.
My app depends on curl,
something like that.
This is really early
for us right now.
If you do have any
suggestions or there's
a use case you think we're
not going to consider,
there is a bug.
It is linked from
our NDK GitHub page.
Please go leave a comment there.
We'd love to hear
from you on that.
It is definitely
not too late for us
to change our plans here.
So yes.
Help us help you.
Try the OS betas.
Try the NDK betas.
Sooner you file
bugs, the more likely
it is that we won't ship them.
It is never fun
when you find out
that the only thing you can do
is work around an existing bug
because it is too
late to fix it.
File bugs at our
GitHub bug tracker.
Give feedback.
Even if you just have
a question to ask,
it's a good place to start.
Worst thing that
will happen is I will
close your bug with an answer.
If you do have
questions you want
to talk to us
about in person, we
do have office hours
tomorrow morning at 8:30.
If you are anything like me
and that sounds terrible,
we will also be around
at 2:00 in the afternoon.
And thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]